describe story was made for walking life
or berbés
trying to pigeonhole the very old in
a gender thing is a need of the
other
we who do not want to legitimize ourselves
because we do not need anyone not
legitimate to do because this being
exists before it could be spoken  A lot
of gender theories
is that
male person who is born biologically with a
biological determination of macho but
culturally
develops roles that are far from
masculine.
The woman has a history that goes
beyond 1521 but from 1521 to the
present she has had to live in
simulation and silence
the native language of this region
is Zapotec and Zapotec does not have the
pronoun for man for woman as if
there is in English with the gil the yes or as
if in Spanish he or she from my
reflection I would say  that it's not the mullen and it
's the lot, it's a lot
[Music]
if you ask me what my
gender identity is, it's what I think about the least
[Music]
of the  The way I'm dressed
now, it's like the tip of Laynce
Verde, being a lot would say when I
agree to wear Zapotec women's clothes, it
's
a political position to say that
anyone who has the decision to do what
they have the freedom to do
[Music]
and the candles should be understood as a
party, I think as a desire and an
opportunity to
feel full even for a moment.
I think that the most powerful action that
the candles have had is to generate
shielding,
so I think a lot with the candles.  that
now our own existence is a
little less painful and less contained, it
would be nice if people, at the
moment they leave their houses and open their
doors
, gender identity won't matter much,
just have a
salt pan that gives them sunlight and that's it
[Music]